in a country where school shootings
happen almost once a week this is what
police have been training for
[Music]
okay okay yes ma'am
let's go
inside almost 200 staff and primary
school children are hiding
[Music]
chills are still in cubby holes
workbooks on tables
whatever it is
an alarm sounds as officers go classroom
to classroom in Pursuit with me
next
if it's upstairs
[Music]
at this point they don't know who the
shooter is or if there's more than one
in fact a 28 year old former student had
broken in through a locked side door
shooting through the glass and climbing
in this is Audrey Hale born a woman and
identifying as a man they know and have
studied the layout of this building over
the course of 14 minutes stalking the
corridors hail shoots dead three
children and three adults
right right right
on the second floor police follow the
sound of gunfire
the shooter is visible for the first
time
then they're gone
killed inside Covenant School where head
teacher Catherine Koontz caretaker Mike
Hill and substitute teacher Cynthia Peak
Hallie Scruggs the nine-year-old
daughter of the school's Pastor was also
murdered
alongside two of her classmates William
Kinney and evening decaus
there's a lot of Praise here for the
Swift police response but clearly it
wasn't soon enough to save those six
victims and so there's a lot of
soul-searching too about America's gun
laws this is the Christmas card of one
of the people who represents Nashville
in government Congressman Andy ogles
posing with his children holding assault
rifles like the one used in this
shooting but when questioned by Sky News
he was Unapologetic why would I regret
taking a family photo with my family and
exercising my constitutional rights
President Biden called once more for a
ban on these weapons of war it was
echoed here to
do a lot of things to change because
we are losing a lot of lives we send
them to school in the morning and we
don't know if we are going to pick them
up in the afternoon
everyone here hopes it will not happen
to their school their supermarket their
City this is Nashville's tragedy the
latest but almost certainly not the last